vice president Kamala Harris reportedly
ready to campaign extensively for
President Biden I guess that's code for
they're going to keep him in the
basement
uh that is as soon as he announces that
he's running if he does that road show
despite many reports that even those
closest to the vice president say she is
not ready not up to the many tasks the
president has already given her here's
the Wall Street Journal with the
headline Kamala Harris prepares to hit
the road for Biden despite cracks in her
support
more here liability to the 2024 ticket
doesn't perform consistently Harris
herself is the biggest impediment to her
political future unable to instill
confidence critics say vice president
Kamala Harris has underperformed on that
to-do list which includes root causes of
migration
illegal immigration voting rights
protections vaccine education tour we
could go on but we don't have that much
time left in the show meanwhile she's
all in for 2024.
as our Joe Biden has said he intends to
run and if he does I will be running
with him Joe Biden intends has said he
intends to run for reelection as
president and I intend to run with him
as Vice President of the United States
how about that brutal polling the real
clear politics average puts the vice
president at 56 percent job disapproval
only 36 percent approve of her
clay Travis out kick founder with
numbers like that he could stay in the
basement and not have her and have the
same results
first congrats to your Chiefs I haven't
seen you since the Super Bowl so I'm
sure you're still gloating a little bit
from
your daughter you
it's great to meet your daughter as well
I know you guys had a fabulous time Joe
Biden
thank you uh Kamala as well
he managed to pick the only person I
really do believe this that could be
less popular than him so if you're going
to give Joe Biden credit the only thing
that he has managed to do is he picked
the worst vice president someone so bad
that Democrats could say you know what
Joe even at 82 years old even at the
disastrous economic climate that you
have created the southern border is a
mess crime is at uh 21st century highs
even with everything that you touch
turning literally to crap it feels like
in almost every field we've got to run
you because we're terrified of how bad
Kamala Harris will get beaten I mean I
gotta I gotta hand it to Kamala she's
the only politician in America who might
well be less popular than Joe Biden and
congratulations to Joe Biden on managing
to make that pick Dr doctor or excuse me
deals are getting an earful from a
person who refuses to take the covet
vaccine over concerns that it was rushed
to Market The Exchange happened back in
2021 part of a now upcoming documentary
they saved the tape here it is
the people in America are not settled
with the information that's been given
to us right now so I'm not going to be
lining up taking a shot on a vaccination
for something that wasn't clear in the
first place if it allowed thousands of
people like you don't get vaccinated
you're going to let this virus continue
to percolate in this country and in this
world something like the common fluid in
right when you start talking about
incentivizing things to get people
vaccinated there's something else going
on with that
oh my goodness no wonder we didn't get
to see it till now that documentary is
going to be interesting American Masters
and you say what clay
I say first of all I love that Dr fauci
has provided the own receipts of his
lies for all of us to dissect but more
importantly that man in two minutes I'd
encourage everybody to go watch that
clip in two minutes he asked tougher
questions of Dr fauci than the left-wing
media has in three years and I think he
epitomizes the innate common sense that
many Americans have as it pertains to
their own health and their own
well-being of their families and the
choices that we all make every single
day as parents and as children and as
part of family units in general and I
think he asked so many questions that
our own media was failing to ask and I
give immense credit to him for having
the wherewithal and frankly the the
willingness to stand up to fauci and the
mayor of D.C there on basically live
television with cameras for all he knew
without knowing how that was going to be
characterized he looks like a hero we
needed more people like him instead of
all the sheep that we ended up with and
much other National media you know
what's interesting a lot of grief was
put on supporters of President Trump who
felt one way or the other about vaccine
but you see there in the black community
no doubt that there was a lot of angst
and concern about this vaccine and
blacks you know a percentage of us were
not represented well in terms of just
having some basic concerns about it and
what didn't help the then candidate for
vice president Kamala Harris saying that
if Trump made the vaccine she wouldn't
get it
so you see how it was tough in those
black communities we never got to see
that represented in this documentary
apparently we will
uh that's a great point because I think
uh to your point all of the argument has
been about the red States in reality a
lot of different minority groups agreed
I'll bring you back thank you very much
great to see you thanks for watching hey
everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me and
my co-host Harris Faulkner and Kaylee
mcineny on outnumbered every weekday at
12 pm Eastern or sets your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights